so as you watch this I'm either just
about to go on holiday or I've just come
back so life has been pretty hectic and
busy I thought I'd try and squeeze in a
quick video here so that I could upload
you with something or not leave you
hanging whilst I was away so today I
wanted to discuss the difference between
isolation exercises compound exercises
and calisthenics and specifically which
ones are the best in terms of functional
strength aesthetics etc because a lot of
people have some very strong opinions on
these matters and you might find that
there's some information you're not
aware of that could help you to reassess
those opinions
[Music]
so the conventional view that a lot of
people take is that compound exercises
are more effective than isolation
exercises compound exercises being
multi-joint exercises that includes
things like the squat like the bench
press the deadlift clean and snatch
anything where you're using multiple
muscles at once in unison so this
requires coordination it requires the
muscles to work as a single unit and
that is how you use them in the real
world if you're pushing furniture around
if you're pulling down something I don't
know what you pull down in the real
world that was a weird example but if
you're essentially using your strength
in the real world you don't just use one
joint as in isolation exercises
isolation exercises are your bicep curls
your tricep extensions your lap pull
downs here you are fixed into place lat
pull-downs less so you're fixed into
place and you're using just one or
perhaps two joints and that really
isolates all the focus onto one muscle
but that is not how you use your muscles
in the real world so yes like I say a
lot of people these days in particular
prefer compound exercises because they
think they're more functional they think
they are closer to how you'd move in the
real world exemplify on this you have
your seven primal movements this is the
notion that there are seven basic
movements on top of which all other
movements can be built so these are gate
which is walking and running lunging
squatting bending talk pushing which
includes vertical push and horizontal
push pulling which is vertical pull and
horizontal pull notice that bicep curls
are not on that list so in other words
these are the movements that everyone
should be able to do that we would have
been able to do in the wild and that we
would have used a lot during our
evolution and thus they are the most
functional the most useful and all of
these compound movements involve piling
lots of weight on top and then doing
those movements so squat is of course
squatting you can do a lunge you can do
gait with something like farmer's walk
you can do talk with this axe exercise
using the cable pulley machine you get
the idea a lot of people will also tell
you that compound movements are what you
need to do
if you want to get bigger and the reason
they site for this is that using
multiple muscle groups in unison
triggers the release of more anabolic
hormones like testosterone like growth
hormone this has been shown in studies
that you do release more of these
hormones during exercises of that nature
and in theory it follows that you would
build more muscle as a result thus many
people say that the most important thing
you can do if you want to become a big
bodybuilder type is to do squats and
deadlifts etc and then you have all
those CrossFitters like rich Froning who
appear to support this theory
thus the isolation exercises the
traditional movements used by a lot of
bodybuilders the isolation curl the
tricep kickback etc these are going the
way of the dodo the leg extension the
hamstring curls people are saying that
these exercises aren't functional they
like to cause injury imbalances and that
they don't build as much muscle but the
first thing I want to do is to defend
the isolation movement because I think
that there's a lot of merit in isolation
movement and it's actually something
that everyone should be doing as a part
of their routine whether or not you are
interested in functional strength
whether or not you're interested in
looking great first of all if you want
to create micro tears and metabolic
stress which are the things you need in
order to create hypertrophy muscle
growth in any specific area then you do
need our isolation exercises so there
are lots of theories as to how
hypertrophy works but generally the
concept is that the more you curl when
you're lifting a heavy enough weight you
create tiny tears in the muscle fiber
called micro tears these then heal with
satellite cells come back thicker and
stronger the muscle gets bigger at the
same time the muscle is also pumped with
more fluids it stores more fluids as you
train for endurance and those exercises
we do an isolation exercise such as a
curl you're focusing just on that muscle
and this really isolates it focuses all
of those micro tears and all that
metabolic stress on that muscle when you
do a exercise like a squat or a bench
press you're using so many different
muscles at once that they're not focused
you're not focusing all the effort on
just one but more importantly when
you're doing an isolation exercise you
can go to failure and you can go beyond
failure so you can do as many bicep
curls as you can physically do
then give up then lower the weight and
do a drop set continue to go and what
this does is it creates those micro
tears you pick up the lighter weight you
create even more micro tears meanwhile
your swelling the area with blood which
is what's causing the metabolic stress
your occluding it you're preventing the
blood from escaping that's what gives
you that sensation of pump the greatest
feeling you can get in a gym or the most
satisfying feeling you can get in the
gym is the pump let's say you train your
biceps blood is rushing into your
muscles and that's would record a pump
you muscles get a really tight feeling
like your skin is going to explode any
minute you know it's really tight it's
like somebody blowing air into into your
muscle it just blows up and it feels
different it feels fantastic and then
you're essentially just really nuking
that muscle and you just can't do that
with a multi joint exercise the reason
being that if you're doing a squat and
you start to suffer if one muscle starts
to become weaker than the others then
you have to stop if you're squatting and
your hamstrings aren't as strong as say
your back or if your glutes aren't as
strong then you'll have to put down the
weight and you won't be able to complete
the repetition but none of them will
have gone to failure it's also not safe
to keep going through drop sets and to
aim for your 1 rep max without a spotter
so you just can't create the same kind
of isolated damage to the muscle that
you need in order to trigger massive
growth you have to stop before you get
to that point and as for the body
producing more anabolic hormones during
these exercises that actually doesn't
have as much as I've bearing as you
might think
studies show that the testosterone and
the growth woman that you produce during
these big compound lifts and any
exercise don't actually contribute to
hypertrophy so it is truly produce more
when you do the compound lifts but it
doesn't make any difference anyways you
know when you watch an action film or
when you have sex or when you see
someone win a race these are also things
that trigger testosterone releasing the
body but none of those things are going
to help you to build muscle it's a quick
spike it doesn't affect your regular
levels of testosterone and thus it
doesn't affect anabolism so the whole
notion that you have to do these big
lifts in order to create more hormonal
response in order to get bigger is
incorrect and let's not forget
muscle endurance in itself is also
functional it's all very good and well
being able to lift something really
heavy once with a big compound lift but
in many ways it's actually more useful
more of the time in the real world to be
able to lift something quite heavy
lots of times such as whether you're
carrying heavy bags home from Tesco or
they were wrestling somebody
bodybuilding using isolation exercises
for large rep ranges causes sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy fills up the cytoplasm
inside the muscle cells and this gives
you more endurance it allows you to pump
out more reps or the shorter version if
it was good enough for our knee then
it's good enough for us the great thing
about the compound moves you'll be
building up those small supporting
muscles that get missed with isolation
because nobody does you know an
isolation day for their brachialis or
for their services muscles I'm not
telling you not to do compound movements
like I say they are more functional they
are closer to what we do you know in the
wild
during our evolution but I'm also saying
don't throw the baby out with the
bathwater isolation movements are still
very important especially if you're
interested in hypertrophy and size and
if you're interested in building pure
strength then they're important as well
because of course you're strengthening
the the links in that chain and
isolating the muscles that are the
primary movers at the same time you can
bring up areas that are perhaps lagging
behind you can focus on specific
weaknesses in your form and your
physique so there's a lot of reason to
kind of spot focus on a specific muscle
whether you're interested in performance
or aesthetics so the best way to combine
these different types of training is by
doing the compound movements at the
start of the workout whilst you've got
full strength and that will also get you
a little bit of a pre burn on the
muscles and then you can focus on
specific areas following that and this
lends itself tickly well to a push-pull
leg split which is my preferred split
but of course there are lots of
different ways
you can manage this the other thing I
want to address is that even compound
movements aren't quite as functional as
many people would assume they are very
functional but they're still practicing
a very specific movement and the very
ideal circumstances so what you're doing
when you do a deadlift is you're
squatting down to the weight you're
picking up off the floor you're standing
up and people say this teaches you to
get better at picking things up what it
really teaches is get better at though
is picking up bars from a stationary
position on a flat floor in real world
whether you're helping someone move
house or doing anything else you're
going to be picking up weights they're a
different shape you're gonna be moving
backwards whilst carrying them you're
gonna be carrying them downstairs and in
the wild you just plain wouldn't have
ever done a deadlift you wouldn't really
have that much need to pick up anything
heavy if you did it apart to be a rock
you probably be standing on uneven
ground your grip would be all over the
place so really if you're training a
very specific technique that's not
terribly functional and if you're saying
you need to get that technique perfectly
right otherwise you're gonna injure
yourself and that's not terribly
functional because again in the wild you
to be prepared for every different
scenario you need to be prepared for
differences in the level of the ground
differences in the shape of what you're
lifting if you look at an animal an
animal doesn't warm up before it goes
running it doesn't need to use correct
form it just instinctively runs it jumps
it fights it lifts if it's a gorilla but
probably still nothing that heavy and it
does all this without thinking without
using correct technique it's just so
strong that it can handle all these
different things and in my recent video
on old-time strongmen I talked about how
they did the anyhow lifts and all these
different moves that have been moving
away from the weight or lifting unusual
shapes and doing these things is a great
way to build a kind of much more
functional strength at the same time
calisthenics is very good for this
because we need to cast the next a
you're using your bodies it's meant to
be used in the wild like I said you
wouldn't really have picked up things
but you would have done it climb trees
jumped over ravines swam done mounts as
you climbed mountains you'd have them
press up type stuff I guess all these
types of movements are real movements
and they again a very compound they're
very natural they use all of your
muscles in conjunction and to an even
greater extent in many ways than a lot
of the compound lifts you try doing the
plank or a handstand press up you're
using your entire core you're
controlling you're aware of your whole
body
this isn't incredibly
functional type of training when you
climb a tree you have to not only pull
yourself up but you're grabbing
different widths of branches you're
clinging on at different levels you're
pulling using completely different
combination of muscles on every single
repetition and that's what true
functional strength is its adaptability
it's being able to adapt to your
surroundings and not have to use a
specific form not being able to say I
can't use my strength in this context so
if you want to be as functional as
possible you need a rounded kind of
strength and that's actually why it's
best to use all three types of training
in your workouts to focus on those
specific muscles and build up the
strength to build those weaknesses you
have in your body to learn correct
technique for complicated compound
movements to build mind muscle
connection and to be able to adapt to
different situations to use your body
the way it was designed to be used so
those people who prefer one type of
training to another that's perfectly
fine
but don't be known the others don't say
that one is better than the other
objectively because they all have their
place and if you want the greatest
strength you should combine all three
together in a well-designed training
program so there's just a little bit of
a rant hope you found it somewhat
interesting there's a lot more I have to
say on this topic it just slipped my
mind like I say this is just a quick
video I wanted to sneak in before I went
away perhaps it takes me a while to edit
it and you're seeing after I get back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
either way let me know what you think in
the comments I've done two on fitness
and muscle building recently because the
last one was quite a hit but I'm gonna
be covering some more topics in future
videos including brain training I wanted
to do another video on nootropics I'll
be discussing that GPT pocket I want to
get some footage of using it abroad
because that's really part of the appeal
of it so yeah if you'd like to see that
and stay tuned please consider liking
and sharing this video it really helps
me out like I say the channel is getting
some momentum I'm super excited about
that head over and follow me on Twitter
Facebook etc I'd love to see you there
and just thanks a ton for watching and
I'll see you next time bye for now